as more americans fly again we're seeing
long lines of security checkpoints
and the tsa may not have enough staff to
keep up in some cases passengers have
been asked to arrive
three hours early to ensure they make
their flights
nearly six million americans traveled
over this weekend that's a huge jump
from only one and a half million over
the same weekend last year
our errol barnett is at reagan national
airport outside washington d.c
errol good morning so what can you tell
us about this staff
shortage hey there good morning you know
it's interesting the tsa is just one of
many
entities short staffed right now
restaurants retail and small businesses
are reporting
the same thing earlier this year the tsa
made a pledge to hire 6 000 security
officers by summer
it's only halfway there and the
resurgent crowds are already here
american air travelers are hitting
pandemic peaks but across the country
there's proof of a security staffing
shortage
it was long and slow like this is crazy
according to a tsa memo obtained by the
washington post
235 airports are currently understaffed
including some of the nation's busiest
like boston logan
denver international and washington
dulles with some airports short as many
as 100
offices so there's a long process in
getting an employee ready to clean
passengers for their safety
heydrich thomas is the president of the
tsa officers union
and is skeptical the agency will hit its
hiring target
so why do you think the tsa won't hit
its benchmark right now there's not too
many people applying for this job maybe
because of the pay
you know they look at other federal
agencies and compare the paid
the tsa says it is quote well positioned
to meet rising travel of volumes and is
on pace with established benchmarks to
meet hiring goals
now part of its recruitment pitch
includes a one thousand dollar incentive
for new hires
over the weekend passenger screenings at
tsa checkpoints were at about 77 percent
of their pre-pandemic levels and it's
only expected to push higher
the recovery in leisure travel demand is
taking almost
anyone in the airline industry by
surprise
travel industry analyst henry hardeveldt
says while more tsa staff
are certainly needed airline schedules
are also part of the problem
you can only travel when the airlines
have flights going
and if they have flights leaving at
seven in the morning and seven pm
then that's when you go and guess what
if all the other flights are leaving at
7am and 7pm
then there's going to be a bottleneck
everybody just needs to pack a little
patience
as they go to the airport this summer
preach and to mr hardeville's point
behind me there was a very long american
airlines
baggage check-in line it's now lowered
as people head to the security line
now the tsa is uh asking office staff to
volunteer
they'll help direct traffic they won't
screen luggage
but they are offering existing security
officers at these uh short-staffed
airports
an extra 500 bucks to work overtime and
on their days off
mr thomas the union rep told me that is
not enough
tony well it's a tough job not everyone
packs their patience
errol thank you very much it's good
advice
it is good advice but it's you know all
these this big comeback is trying a lot
of people's patience i think
yeah and the economy is not quite ready
we don't have enough workers and a lot
of industries
to keep up with everyone's new behavior
it's a hard job dealing with the public
every day have you seen us in the public
we're not always friendly at the airport
all right errol thank you
again